the russian president's motorcade swept
through a deserted geneva and into the
grounds of the 18th century villa
the spectacle of an event like this is
quite something
vladimir putin was the first to arrive
greeted by the swiss president
the host of a summit full of the
potential for drama
president biden followed it was he who
had initiated this meeting
a chance to put a dangerous relationship
back on track
or at least try to
this was a moment for two men with such
power
to work the other out if relations are
back at cold war times then the library
of old books
complete with a globe for their
competing world visions
well that was apt
and i hope that our meeting will be
productive
well thank you as i said outside i think
it's always better to make facebook
but then away from the cameras the
meetings began the world views of the
two leaders in there are profoundly
different and there's no expectation
that will change
with this meeting there are areas where
potentially they can agree
climate change arms control iran but so
many more
where they will not and so this will be
about creating a more stable
predictable relationship where they can
at least understand their differences
and control the fallout after three
hours
less than was planned they were done and
into separate news conferences
president putin went first and it was
clear immediately
that things went well
i believe that there was no hostility on
the contrary
our meeting took place in a principled
manner our assessments on many points
differ but in my opinion both sides
demonstrated a desire to understand each
other
and look for ways to bring their
positions closer the conversation was
very constructive
human rights and the fate of opposition
leader alexey navalny were brought up by
president biden
here mr putin deflected
people went into the us congress with
political demands
400 people are facing prison terms of up
to 20 maybe 25 years
they're called home-grown terrorists we
can't risk the same thing happening
the american president had been watching
all that before facing the cameras
himself
the tone of the entire meetings i guess
it was totally four hours
was was what was was good
positive there wasn't any any
strident action taken at the end a
telling moment a need clearly to clarify
an important message why are you so
confident he'll change his behavior mr
president
yeah i'm not confident what are you
doing
so when did i say i was coming
they had always played down this meeting
as just the first stage of rebuilding
dialogue and it was precisely that no
trump style drama
no diplomatic moments a little dull even
but then that's no bad thing for a
relationship
which can be so perilous